well tonight a woman is working to put
her life back together after a pickup
truck
barged into her living room it came to a
stop exactly where she'd been sitting
just moments before
the damage still evident near valley
view and sahara in the central valley
and that's where we find madison
kimbrough with the woman's terrifying
story madison is that woman okay
yes her name is francine mchugh and the
soon to be 74 year old is just thankful
to be alive tonight after a pickup truck
ran
into her living room as you can see
right here
saturday evening take a look
well i was sitting at the table as usual
what made me move i don't know
francine mchugh has been a resident of
sunrise gardens senior living for three
years
and this past saturday she almost lost
her life after a white pickup truck
rammed into her apartment by time i
reached the doorknob the big boom went
and everything came at me before the
incident the driver of the truck
allegedly hit a man that was crossing
the street
metro describing it as an attempted
homicide the driver of the truck then
sped off landing right into francine's
living room i've never seen so much
glass in my life and so scared
and trapped and i could not get out i
could not move
i don't walk luckily francine made it to
the door and squeezed herself
out francine's neighbor nancy vasquez
recalls hearing a loud noise followed by
repeated screaming
i heard a big crash like i heard a bunch
of glass it went
and i said oh crap i thought the
neighbor upstairs had fallen out of the
bathtub
francine says she thought the white
pickup truck was going to blow up
as she screamed for help and for her dog
toto who she later found
unharmed once she made it outside and i
was thankful she got out ok
because i don't know god was on her side
that night the angels were there
and the two people in the pickup truck
were detained and taken into custody
as far as charges go metro has not
released that information yet but we
will keep a lookout
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now